[Music]
the late Anna Nicole Smith's daughter
Dannielynn is in a good happy space
yesterday we showed you how the 11-year
old and her father Larry Birkhead are
living a very normal life in Kentucky
but you know what it wasn't always that
way
can I ask you can we talk about some of
the stuff you went through some of the
craziness you went through all right
let's you tell me we'll go down the list
okay let's go down the list okay how
much time you get the first time I saw
you in LA was that that infamous
interview with her the night she went on
the American Music Awards understand
here with you online and split all my I
want this guy to produce you mom make me
beautiful what was going on that day
what was going on with her I will say
this as bad as that seemed that people
were making fun of her but behind the
scenes her phone was ringing off the
hook people were dropping off scripts
people wanted to do interviews I mean
and unfortunately that's the way it goes
people people were talking about her
Larry also revealed a secret from his
paternity battle with Anna Nicole's
attorney Howard case turned right there
you can see Burke head hold a piece of
paper with his DNA results but he never
actually showed it to reporters today he
keeps it in his closet there's a few
treasures in here one of the things that
nobody's ever seen before is my actual
DNA test that I got when I was holding
up and I came out of the courtroom yeah
the judge told me I couldn't show it to
anybody at the time I remember that
moment well so I had it rolled up and
Nicole also kept secrets in her journal
so this is a Anna's diary and her
planner she was keeping this is really
bright when she got started with all her
movies and she was doing The Naked Gun
she was doing guests she was doing the
Playboy but in this calendar what's so
funny is she's in
November of 1993 she's excited about her
career where it's going and she talks
about she's filming Entertainment
Tonight
and then she's gonna is gonna air in
November of 93 God loves me this is the
interview and I wrote about 25 years ago
I had a lot of them people who didn't
think I was gonna be anything growing up
and they always picked I had a lot of
people pick on me and stuff Anna also
wrote in her diary how she yearned to
have a baby girl and I want more
children I want a girl I can dress up
and I don't think I'll ever get married
because men are pigs that was first you
met me in my defense it's such a blur
all the stuff and I just think about I
think did all that happened to me I
would probably think I was dreaming the
whole thing good wasn't for Daniel
[Music]
you